qui n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir sa propre
maison en bois la construction bois un
secteur en pleine progression ces
dernières années une sorte de retour aux
origines - aujourd'hui est le matériau
le plus vieux du monde qui a été utilisé
pendant des siècles et il est non
polluant puisqu'il vient stocker du gaz
carbonique
il est aujourd'hui résistant je lui
d'avoir une maison en bois c'est aussi
un gage de qualité
la bourgogne franche comté est l'un des
territoires en pointe dans la
construction bois aujourd'hui dans la
région une maison sur cinq se construit
à partir de ce matériau
de leur côté les entreprises se tournent
également de plus en plus vers le bois
et pour s'en rendre compte on va sortir
rapidement du salon une des preuves de
cette transition écologique ses bureaux
situés au coeur du parc valmy à dijon 8
193 mètres carrés de bâtiments
entièrement construit en bois mais vous
allez voir d'autres projets d'envergure
sont à venir d'ici 2020 la zone de valmy
de dijon prendra les airs d'un
écoquartier parmi les projets une
nouvelle banque mais aussi un grand
parking
conçu à partir de bois bourguignon
ce que vous voyez là c'est le premier
parking entièrement en bois complètement
démontable et remontable ce qui permet
deux choses maintenir le foncier est de
réduire les gaz à effet de serre dans un
futur dans laquelle on pourrait réduire
les voitures en ville
le deuxième intérêt c'est que c'est le
bois qui vient du morvan est donc de
développer la filière bois construction
bois du nord alors si tous ces projets
montrent une certaine dynamique
il n'en reste pas moins vrai que la
construction bois peu à l'achat coûter
plus cher que le béton ce qui peut
freiner les particuliers dans leur
projet de maison en revanche en ce qui
concerne les extensions la part de
marché de la filière bois ne cesse de
grimper